voici l'objet de tous les désirs un
hélicoptère ec145 plus connus ici en
guadeloupe sous son indicatif radio
dragon 971 construit par airbus
industrie cette machine est considéré
comme l'une des meilleures plateformes
de secours et d'assistance à personne en
2018 l'hélicoptère de la sécurité civile
a effectué plus de 800 mission dans
l'archipel la plupart pour le compte du
ca 1971
désormais il va falloir partager la
machine et ses équipages avec la
martinique une situation déjà vécue par
le passé avant que la martinique
un dragon bn avec un pour les deux îles
donc nous sommes habitués à ce cas de
figure c'est vrai que l'arrivée du
dragon la martinique ces dernières
années nous a permis de le solliciter en
plus d'une autre car nous avons beaucoup
de missions mais nous revenons un
scénario que nous avions connu il faut
savoir que en dehors des hélicoptères de
la sécurité civile
des hélicoptères de la gendarmerie
peuvent être utilisés ou mobilisés pour
le secours à personne bien que ce ne
soit pas leur mission principale est
donc il appartient à la zone antilles de
déterminer de répartir les moyens sud
des deux territoires tout cas pour la
population de la guadeloupe
nous optimisons avec moi que nous avons
des heures de vol au profit d'une
population dragon 971 a déjà été engagé
une première fois au profit de la
martinique il a participé hier aux
recherches pour localiser l'avion de la
dg ac qui s'est écrasé au nord de l'île
de la dominique